[Applause]
have you ever heard of a guy named
peacemaker no
he is a trained killer
we've got trouble with that maniac
go what are you waiting for
that thing better not crap back there
yeah i'll strain an eagle dude that
without stealing its soul
hey dad
it's been a kind of rough goal from the
daily dad you don't say somebody shot me
a building fell on me you let somebody
shoot you it's not gonna invite him to
come shoot me dad
pathetic
i thought you're in prison for life i
work for the government
post office do you think they'd let me
out of prison and deliver mail i don't
know it's the first government job i
could think of i killed people for them
okay
this task force doesn't officially exist
which leaves us on our own we call our
targets butterflies they are a serious
threat to the safety of american
citizens
there's something weird going on you
think me and vigilante are too stupid to
notice hey everyone which one's me and
which one's easily okay you're half
right but you score 50 of the test at
school what do you get
school wasn't my bag it's for dorks
that guy's a clown but there's something
about him that's
sad
is your target in sight peacemaker take
them out even the kids yes terminate
them immediately
take the socks
he told me to kill kids he didn't say
why
because right now the world needs the
son of a [ __ ] you're the only one i got
i thought you loved peace no matter how
many men women and children you needed
to kill to get it
i don't know think i'm having feelings
about things
[Music]
dad maybe i'm a grower
not a shower what an individual you
don't like and then you learn to like
you're comparing yourself to a chode
not a bad way your dad is not a good man
he's still family my advice cut it out
with the introspection the mind is a den
of scorpions better left running from
not towards
[Applause]
[Music]
no
two jerks and costumes and a couple of
rejects
it's like a real team out there
yo what the hell is that it's a grenada
tied to a russian tank shell why not
just the grenade gertie blows up like
two people how many people does this
blow up i don't know i invented it this
morning what
eat peace [ __ ]
[Music]
you